llegó el momento entonces hablar de
revista de prensa hoy lunes ya iniciamos
semana rosa feliz lunes para ti muy buen
día vamos a empezar hablando de una gran
investigación periodística liderada por
el medio alemán süddeutsche zeitung y el
centro investigación organised crime and
corruption reporting project en la que
han participado casi 50 medios de
comunicación rosa conjuntamente para
revelar qué hay detrás de los secretos
bancarios de change switch el segundo
mayor banco de suiza buenos días raúl
exactamente y de esta decena de medios
que han participado en esta
investigación hemos querido seleccionar
the gardian lo en mont la nación por
ejemplo the gardian titula la filtración
de credit suisse desenmascara a
criminales defraudadores y políticos
corruptos lemont señala swiss secrets
revelaciones sobre el dinero suizo
escondido de credit suisse o la nación
de argentina destaca salar salen a la
luz los secretos del cofre suizo y estos
secretos es que a pesar de que este
banco de suiza e indicara anteriormente
que iba limpiarnos sus arcas de dinero
procedente del crimen organizado o de la
corrupción ahora la investigación
encuentra que ha lucrado y que ha
conservado ocho mil millones de dólares
en cuentas ligadas a políticos corruptos
delincuentes condenados espías y
dictadores y the gardian tiene un mapa
donde señala por ejemplo ucrania
tailandia egipto o venezuela como países
con más ciudadanos implicados en esta
lista que ha salido ahora a la luz para
señalar simplemente algunos casos vemos
cómo está presente en esta lista la
élite venezolana acusada de saquear la
petrolera estatal pdvsa también el jefe
de inteligencia de egipto que no había
supervisado torturas de sospechosos de
terrorismo para la cia o el rey abdalá
segundo de jordania y precisamente tal y
como señala la nación son perfiles muy
variados pero que se han aprovechado de
esta ley de secretos bancarios que es
tan característica de suiza por lo que
muchos consideran este país europeo una
paraíso fiscal de hecho al conde
el artículo que hemos seleccionado de la
nación señala por encima de sus relojes
de lujo sus montañas nevadas y su
excelente chocolate suiza es sobre todo
conocida por el secretismo de su sector
bancario y en el corazón de esta
industria está el credit suisse un banco
que ya está sentado en el banquillo de
los acusados porque la fiscalía lo acusa
de permitir el blanqueo de dinero del
narcotráfico y hemos querido señalar
como veíamos antes precisamente la
tribuna de gide ahora que además critica
que esta ley de secretos bancarios
impide que los medios de comunicación
puedan hablar de papeles filtrados de de
secretos bancarios y por qué se
arriesgan a ir a la prisión no aquí
vemos a la justicia suiza amordazando a
la prensa muchas restricciones para la
prensa lamentable y rosa vamos ahora con
el fin de los juegos olímpicos de
invierno que tanta polémica ha generado
pues ya lo vimos con camila valía va y
otras más pero vamos ahora a ver el
balance según el globe and time sedes de
china y el 'new york times' desde eeuu
exacto aprovechando que ayer fue esta
ceremonia de clausura nos hemos querido
fijar en cómo se titula desde un lado y
desde el otro por un lado el 'global
times' en la editorial de hoy dice los
juegos olímpicos de invierno de beijing
le dan al mundo un abrazo cálido y
curativo los juegos han llevado
esperanza a la gente alrededor del mundo
durante el frío invierno de la pandemia
y además han inyectado una valiosa dosis
de paz y unidad en un mundo turbulento y
destacan el éxito de china frente al
fracaso del llamado boicot diplomático y
a las calumnias de algunos medios
occidentales por otro lado el 'new york
times' rápidamente dice con la ceremonia
de clausura china celebra un triunfo
pero sin alegría según los periodistas
de steven lee myers y que vendrán desde
beijing escriben que los juegos terminan
sin ningún desastre pero ensombrecidos
por un escándalo de dopaje el aumento de
las tensiones en europa y la ansiedad
sobre el futuro del deporte pero también
uno se pregunta qué tipo de desastre
esperaban también estos periodistas de
la 'new york times' no lo sabemos no lo
sabemos rosa y vamos ahora con un tema
que estábamos avanzando el día viernes
una extensa investigación de conectas y
aris sobre el poder de los planes de
venezuela en las grandes ligas eso es un
reportaje interactivo rosa efectivamente
como es interactivo es un poco difícil
demostrar porque es muy entretenido pues
de ver directamente sobre el ordenador
pero básicamente con distintas pantallas
explica de qué manera los pranes estos
líderes de las prisiones en la venezuela
pues se introducen dentro de las ligas
de béisbol desde las mas benjamines
hasta las profesionales y extorsionan
pues a los principales jugadores que
firman por ejemplo con las grandes ligas
de estados unidos oa las academias las
que han pertenecido y entre otras cosas
vemos una página donde pues se describen
distintos casos que han sido conocidos
de jugadores de peloteros que han
denunciado esta extorsión de forma
pública como el caso de miguel cabrera
que en 2017 dijo que estaba cansado de
pagar vacunas pero es que es tanto el
poder que tienen los planes y su afición
por el béisbol llega a tales es que en
algunos casos llegan a construir
estadios dentro de las propias prisiones
ya invitar a jugadores profesionales
como aquí vemos pues el tren de aragua
de arauca está esta banda pues llegó a
construir en la prisión de tocorón un
campo de béisbol completamente
profesional con el césped artificial
rauch
y muchísimas gracias entonces por este
investigue por esta revista de prensa
vale la pena también que nuestros
televidentes vean esta investigación
porque es realmente bastante interesante
nos vemos mañana con más de nuestra
revista de prensa vamos a pasar ahora a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado al día